Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Victor Barange.
Ca va Victor ?
-Salut ! Salut Fabien ! Ouais super !
Compositeur, interprète...
-Wow !
Tout ça ?!
Et il fait de la maçonnerie à coté.
[rires]
-Mais que les week-end.
Donc comme il est venu faire un mur et qu'il est avec sa guitare, j'ai dit "faisons une vidéo !"
-Exactement, ouais, exactement !
Attends je vais me recoiffer...
Wow ! La je suis bien, je suis au top.
Et moi tu sais que ce sont des faux. Ce sont des faux cheveux.
J'ai quand même réfléchi à ce que pouvait faire ensemble.
Ce que j'aimerai, c'est que tu penses dans ta tête à une chanson connue, si possible une chanson française, et tu penses à cette chanson là, tu ne le dis pas.
-Ok.
Tu me dis quand c'est bon.
-Trouvé !
Trouvé ?
Super.
Alors je vais utiliser la guitare pour essayer de la retrouver.
-Impossible !
J'ai une bonne culture de la chanson française, et comme je t'ai demandé quelque chose que tout le monde connaît en temps normal je suis censé la connaître.
On est d'accord ?
-T'es censé la connaître.
-Obligé !
Alors je vais essayer de lâcher des notes, sur la chanson.
Toi, tu n'es pas obligé de penser au début de la chanson, pense à ce qui est le plus connu, en général ce sont les refrains qui sont les plus connus.
-D'accord.
Dans ta tête, tu me valides mentalement si j'ai bon ou pas.
Par exemple, tu peux te dire "Ah oui tiens ça on dirait un peu le début",
ou "Ca pas du tout"...
Je vais essayer comme ça, de gratter note par note. Je n'ai jamais fait ça.
C'est un peu ce que je fais avec les lettres d'un mot en temps normal.
-Il est ouf !
Ouais... Et là je me demande où je me suis embarqué !
🎵
[rires] Il ne se passe rien du tout, je peux vous dire !
Soit il a un poker face excellent, soit je fais n'importe quoi !
-C'est énorme !
🎵
Ah il y a une petite réaction là, vous avez vu ?
Il a tic ! Il y a juste eu un petit truc là dessus.
🎵
-Si il trouve... [rires] impressionant !
J'essaye de partir sur des choses.
-Je laisse rien transmettre, on est d'accord ?
Tout à fait.
-Ok.
Parce que après il faut que j'associe avec les possibilités que ça engendre et on a vu récemment dans la vidéo avec Lola Dubini que les mêmes accords pouvaient couvrir pleins de chansons !
🎵
Ah ! Il y a une espèce de progression qui est... En fait je vois Victor en attente d'une progression.
-J'attends de trouver une mélodie, tu vois, de m'accrocher à un truc.
[chantonnement de Fabien]
Ca te parle ça un peu, on dirait.
-Ca me parle un peu.
[chantonnement de Fabien]
🎵
-Oh non ! [rires]
Ah ce n'est pas possible !
Alors là pour l'instant je ne sais pas ce que je joue !
Mais apparemment j'ai très bon !
[rires]
Ok.
Bon, alors... Qu'est-ce que je viens de faire...
-Et c'est vraiment ouf, parce que vraiment il ne le sait pas !
Là je me répète mais c'est ouf !
🎵
Ah je l'ai !
[chante] "Je te dirai les nanana na na nana...
-Exact !
na na..."
C'est ça ?!
-Chapeau ! [applaudissements]
C'est "Les mot bleus" ?
-Exactement.
[applaudissements]
👍
Je m'auto félicite !
-Ce mec est malade !
Je m'auto félicite parce que...
-Non mais attends c'est un truc de ouf !
Je crois que c'est le seul moment que je connais de la chanson, c'est ça: "Je te dirai les mots bleus, na nanana..."
[chante]
-Et en cinq sept en plus !
Et en cinq sept, attends !
Bon, alors par contre, je suppose que je l'ai massacré.
-Non, pas tant que ça.
C'est vrai ?
-Pas tant que ça.
Est-ce que tu pourrais nous faire voir ce que c'est "Les mots bleus" ?
Ah oui tu as le médiator.
Je lui dirai les mots bleus,
Ceux qui rendent les gens heureux,
Je l'appellerai sans la nommer,
Je suis peut-être démodé,
Le vent d'hiver souffle en avril
J'aime le silence immobile
D'une rencontre
Je lui dirai les mots bleus
Ceux qui rendent les gens heureux
Je l'appellerai sans la nommer
Je suis peut-être démodé
Le vent d'hiver souffle en avril
J'aime le silence immobile
D'une rencontre
[applaudissements]
Bravo à toi !
J'adore ta voix, et j'adore ton style.
-Merci beaucoup Fabien.
D'ailleurs, son style vestimentaire que je vais vous faire voir tout de suite.
Parce que là vous vous dites: "Ouais, le mec il est classique, habillé d'un petit polo rouge, et petit haut blanc..."
Mais regardez le bas !
-Yoooh !
[rires]
Ça mon pote c'est rock and roll ok ?!
Comment elle s'appelle ta chaine Victor ?
-Elle s'appelle "Barange" tout court.
Elle s'appelle "Barange", tout court.
-Ouais.
B-A-R-A-N-G-E.
Comme ça se prononce.
Vous pouvez cliquer ici, directement sur cette tête pour accéder à la chaine de Barange.
Vous pouvez aussi regarder le lien que je vais mettre dans le descriptif.
Moi, c'est une chaine que je suis depuis un petit moment.
Tu as 100 abonnés.
Et il en mériterait plus que moi. Donc je compte sur vous pour aller au moins visiter la chaine, et si vous kiffez, abonnez-vous.
Vraiment !
Merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la gratifier  d'un léger et sensible, mais musical
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Vous pouvez également nous lâcher un petit com' parce qu'on aime ça, et que je les lis tous.
Et pensez à vous abonner avant de partir, parce que je vous rappelle quand même que le Mental Vlog c'est un vidéo par jour pendant un an,
donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[chante] Il est six heures au clocher de l'église
Dans le square les fleurs poétisent
Une fille va sortir de la mairie
Comme chaque soir je l'attends
Elle me sourit
Il faudra bien qu'elle comprenne
A tout prix
Je lui dirai les mots bleus
Les mots qu'on dit avec les yeux
Je l'appellerai sans la nommer
Je suis peut-être démodé
Le vent d'hiver souffle en avril
J'aime le silence immobile
D'une rencontre
Je lui dirai les mots bleus
Ceux qui rendent les gens heureux
Parler me semble ridicule
Je m'élance et puis je recule
Et tous les longs discours futiles
Terniraient quelque peu le style
De nos retrouvailles